so it turns out it's very very hard to
turn an office building into an
apartment building and some of the
Practical problems are Plumbing so think
about your average office building it's
got uh one restroom two restrooms three
restrooms and then when when it's time
to put in apartments like everyone wants
a restroom so you know like that's a big
problem there are a lot of interior
spaces that might not have Windows which
is a No-No for a lot of Apartments
kitchens the same Jam elevators the
elevators are often not built to the
same specifications they're required for
residential building you've got a lot of
building code problems for residential
conversions it's just not happening I
mean and then on top of it
um you need a lot of zoning changes and
some in New York you need some State Law
changes it's office conversion
residential office conversion is really
really really hard it was okay in some
of the older buildings downtown in New
York so in the financial districts the
buildings were built differently than
modern Office Buildings
um but you know it's really hard to see
residential versions a lot of the
buildings if they're going to become
residential are going to have to be
knocked down yeah and then at that point
it's not much of a conversion you're
like hey let's build an apartment
building yeah I I have been in the
downtown uh office buildings that have
been converted and some of them are very
nice um but they're still also funky
like all the dimensions are funky yeah I
completely agree it's um it's uh it's um
it's it's you can see people sometimes
like funky like it's like Lofts or
whatever they have a little bit of that
feel to them um it's something it's like
a unique space but it is um it's not
going to be a massive source of how is
that particularly because the state and
city are going to require uh if they
ever do allow this they're going to
require a good amount of the apartments
that are created to be uh deed
restricted affordable
um or red restricted and uh the result
will be that the the economics of it
doesn't work out even if you can
overcome some of the building code
changes and so I don't think there's any
real uh realistic opportunities for
residential conversions particularly in
New York in again in the shorter medium
term unless the politics exchange is
pretty substantially yeah and you
mentioned San Francisco which has the
these problems uh revved up even higher
perhaps I mean there there are very
large Office Buildings
um you're saying that their occupancy is
lower than 50 which wouldn't surprise
too much slower yeah San Francisco is
the lowest of any downtown
so is that like 20 25 yeah something
like that I don't have the number of
them but something it's really loud uh
and what's interesting is both New York
and San Francisco these buildings were
premium priced before I mean they could
command crazy rents and then now they
can rent it for any level uh well I mean
it's unclear whether they can rent a
privilege so there's been some some the
the price Discovery has been slow in
this area and there's some reasons you
might imagine something about their
contracts the things that there's been
some lack of desire to take losses which
may affect the banks and there's a
couple of things going on
um but it has been a whether they're
permanently useless
um or temporary useless or just uh in
some kind of stasis due to some kind of
difficulty working out contracts is a
little hard to say you're right is in
that we don't know what the correct
price level is and there are a lot of
incentives in place for them not to rent
something for a song because then
everyone else in the building's like
wait what they're getting it for a song
and then your creditors are like wait
what you're renting it for that level if
you're rented at that level you can
never pay us back uh and and so there
are a lot of folks who are probably
um Frozen in place yeah it's I mean it's
not the problem is in some ways pretty
similar to the problem we've seen in New
York for a while about
um about uh retail vacancies just like
retail space is really expensive in New
York why was it the case that there were
so many retail vacancies even before
covet and the answer was like there were
a lot of difficulties with contracts and
pricing in the way that you described
and so it's a uh it's a it's a we we
might need legal interventions of other
sorts to encourage the market to shake
out a little better yeah the average uh
retail lease is probably something like
four or five years and a lot of folks
aren't able to make that kind of
commitment this will have some effect on
a commercial property tax revenue going
forward which will be a big problem and
please like New York are obviously very
dependent on commercial property taxes
but so are almost all downtowns
um and you're seeing you know
differential problems across
jurisdictions your office office uptake
in southern jurisdictions is much higher
than it is in uh in New York and San
Francisco but it's a problem everywhere
that you're seeing decline in commercial
property values and that is particularly
a fiscal problem because they're
generally taxed in IRAs
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really
really love by you every time we have a
bang-up new guest thank you